- I have to ask though,
I saw this picture online
and I'm just wondering
if you were just going
for the Tom Selleck thing
or this was for "Mario,"
what's happening here in this picture?
- That's New Year's.
I grew out my mustache for something
that I was doing, I'd like
to say that I grew it out
to do the voice.
- You were very method.
Very method.
- Deep into the character.
- Like what would it feel like?
- You just guys do music.
You know how the mustache
affects the sounds.
- Oh, definitely.
- Does that make it rock more, Jack?
- I'm not talking to you guys.
(audience and panel laughing)
But I thought it looked a little more
like a three musketeer.
- I was going D'Artagnan all day long.
- [Jack] Mario doesn't have
the soul patch downstairs,
you know?
- You were working you were working
almost a full Vandyke there.
- Actually all of y'all
in a musketeer movie
would be amazing.
- The three musketeers-
- Yeah, this would be amazing actually.